what's the most exciting thing that you
could sell I want to have a billion
people like I want I want to help eight
billion people I want to help the world
right so there's the mission which is
awesome but then inside of that like you
need to have a monetization strategy and
there's a lot of ways that you could do
it I could be doing World Tour speaking
I could be doing the YouTube channel I
could be selling courses like I woke up
this morning excited to come and do it's
like I get to hang out with a land get
to meet all these people it's going to
be so much fun like what would be fun
for you that then you can also sell
because all of those could work and for
someone like you who loves learning like
you can learn how to make all of those
potentially work learning for the sake
of learning is great but I think if you
don't apply it you're losing on what
you're learning okay so now let's turn
into a business model okay you're not
making enough money because you're not
reaching a lot of people could you have
a low six-figure business probably but
like could you make something bigger
it's hard off of Just YouTube videos
that's targeted a small audience how
many people in America which becomes a
market much more in Canada go through
science like everybody has to take Grade
9 science I mean if you're in school if
you dropped out how many of those
students don't want to fail science
class almost everybody right if you said
how many of them want to get straight
A's not a lot of people like most people
don't think they can get straight but
how many don't want to fail most people
don't want to fail if you are actually a
better instructor than their teachers
the easiest ways for the textbook like
this is your textbook there's 20
sections in the book and here are the
videos that go along and teach you all
of this stuff like in an easier way and
you would get the income from
advertisement on the videos that's your
lowest hanging fruit is AD Revenue let
me change the world that's the plan
thank you
hello welcome morning welcome very happy
to be here Evan you've got a gift here
what is this is crazy this is so on the
floor what it is is like I've been
following you for the last couple years
and I've had great ideas and moving
forward but the issue is I have all the
knowledge here and I need to put it
together so we can move forward the
whole idea of your airplane we talked
about that earlier and the whole idea of
building to serve so I'm working on that
so that's not a problem but looking at
momentum what is the next step and
that's why I'm so excited to be here
today so here what I have is basically a
brain download and so I know a lot of
your brain this is a brain on paper so I
love it I censored some information so
you don't see everything okay but this
is the main idea about knowledge so I
know enough because I've been a teacher
and doing science for 30 years yeah but
I have difficulties right now to package
it and using which platform to make it
easy for me so I can provide values to
the to the audience worldwide so that's
what I'm looking for so I know the
knowledge I have the knowledge of how to
put it together but
what platform do I want to use because
there's so many social media pieces but
then I end up I feel that it's just uh
watering down all the options instead of
saying okay let's focus on one and then
go to the next bit next bit to make to
make a business okay so I mean right now
you're a full-time teacher full-time
teacher yes
getting into entrepreneurship what is
the thing that you want to sell
uh the idea is so my one word is
learning yeah uh so learning is exciting
and I was trying on my way here actually
I was saying okay I would like to bring
moments of learning around the world so
I was thinking a million and that's too
small so on my way here when I got here
it was a billion moments of learning so
that is the goal okay so I have a
YouTube channel for uh for my French
science class so slowly this is growing
because uh I'm part of your Brenda
lytics so that is the one project that
is going well and so I'm working on the
YouTube channel because it can do a few
things I can share my knowledge and I
can help students at the same time but I
have five years where when I retire what
will I do with this so I'm stepping the
stone slowly and uh so these will be
questions like um I have uh so I looked
at the online courses platform which is
great
but then there are five of them and then
I subscribe to one or two and then
there's so much to do that I said just
step back so the knowledge is available
but putting it together so it grows
that's my biggest thing okay so what's
what's your business model going to be
though so okay we want to have a billion
moments of learning I love it it's great
you're in a situation where you don't
necessarily have to go super quick
because you you still have your job but
five years you're gonna retire which is
awesome
what are we going to sell or how are we
going to make money what's the business
model going to be have we have we
thought about that have we figured it
out is that what we're here to talk
about it's one of the things we need to
talk about because in some ways uh as a
teacher you that you learn and then you
share what you have but I'm thinking of
the business aspect of things even
though teaching in school boards are
part of a business
um so what do I said I was thinking of
online courses would be nice uh class
notes possibly I like the idea of the
YouTube channel also eventually getting
to do interviews with different people
so they can bring the knowledge so to
the audience so so what's the most
exciting thing that you could sell like
that actually because inside of I want
to I want to help I want to have a
billion people like I wanna I wanna help
eight billion people or I want to help
the world right
so there's the mission which is awesome
but then inside of that like you need to
have a monetization strategy yes and
there's a lot of ways that you could do
it right I could be doing World Tour
speaking I could be doing the YouTube
channel I could be selling courses I
could be like I could be doing lots of
things
I woke up this morning like excited to
come and do it's like I get to hang out
with LA I get to meet all these people
it's going to be so much fun like what
would be fun for you that then you can
also sell because all of those could
work like everything that you see for
sale with this course or notes or
lectures or YouTube channels or whatever
like all of it could work that's true so
and and for someone like you who loves
learning like you can learn how to make
all of those potentially work yeah
so the one that worked the best is the
one that you actually like feel
connected to in your heart that you
actually are passionate about doing
right so inside of the different options
where you could sell something what are
you most excited about actually making
that's a good question it's it's one of
those
take all of this I was trying to I've
done tutoring which is interesting but
it's one-on-one so it's a bit limited so
I don't think it's scalable I was
looking at possibly having like
so what would you tutor in
um I like the science aspect of life and
how to use science to make the
environment and the world a better place
not just learning for the topics per se
and and then you're you would be
tutoring like students well that's a
good question high school students
because that's what I've done but I've
been teaching for so long yeah uh one
thing I could do is actually helping
other teachers to become better teachers
so that so that is a good aspect
um because adults
so students are great but adults are
great and I think what I can help the
most is helping teachers become better
teachers so they can help most students
okay that is an option pause for one
second yes and let me ask you forget
about scalability okay what's the most
fun for you to do the most fun for me to
do would be Hands-On stuff so if I do
science is to do labs and learn and see
people learning doing Labs or if it is a
language class is to converse or go and
explore different areas so they can you
can use the language so it's the whole
idea of applying uh learning for
learning for the sake of learning is
great but I think if you don't apply it
you're losing on what you're learning
okay so now let's turn into a business
model okay so you said tutoring you like
tutoring but it's not scalable it's too
small but do you love tutoring I would
say that it's probably
50 50. it's it's fun but it's not what I
love the most to do what do you love the
most to do that's a good one that brings
value to other people right because
inside there is a business model yeah uh
what I like the most and I would say
that is probably one of my weakness okay
because I can enjoy and learn to enjoy
anything right so that that it has been
one of my biggest drawback yeah uh it's
a strength and a weakness for sure and
that's that's why so yeah so what do I
love the most uh being here today that's
that's the main thing and that's why
you're learning I know and uh and I want
you to tell I don't want you to tell me
I want you to guide the reflecting
which is you're doing right now okay so
what do I love the most
that serves other people right because
you getting lost in a book or watching a
video or being here learning is great
but unless you help somebody else you
don't have a business right it's just
you learning for the sake of learning
which awesome but like how do you want
to go and help people so what if it's
like if you want The Human Experience
then tutoring could work if you love the
idea of oh I don't want to deal with
people what I want but I like I like
writing
manuals or like writing textbooks or
like writing course notes or but we're
doing something or we're taking our
knowledge this is great A lot of input
and then we got to make we got to have
an output somewhere we're going to make
something that's going to help somebody
else yeah okay so I would say that
what I love is to share what I know and
make it easy to to get so you touch a
few points
um the difficulty so if I could have for
example a website where I have a place
where I have videos so people bring in
questions and I can answer their
questions I can have a Blog I think a
Blog may be better than a textbook where
you can just put information online so
that people could go there and actually
learn something those moments of
learning for example okay so so like
rewinding that a little bit yeah before
you even worried about if there's a blog
or a book or whatever do you like
writing
or do you like making videos or do you
like working with people one-on-one
I would say that I prefer to do videos
and writing okay above being with people
all the time okay I think it's probably
the introvert part yeah definitely so
that's that's how it is yeah
um and is there a preference between
writing and making videos I think that
at this time it's videos okay even
though I discovered a website where it
can transcribe the video so I could use
the videos to do the writing and then
put it together so I think that's
something that I would enjoy so you so
you love making videos yes okay yep so
that's why the YouTube that's the one
thing that I started following you for a
while I still do well and earlier today
you said it's it's the one area where
you actually have some momentum and
growth happening okay so if you look at
what I like for example I have every
Saturdays I have a life and I answer
questions so a few people come and I use
my students question to be able to to
feed the video one thing I was
reflecting on a few days ago was
if I could have a place where people can
just answer their questions and then I
could just ask their question and then I
can answer them because sometimes you
don't need a tutor for an hour because
an hour is great but at some point
I'm here to help a person but after 20
minutes usually I'm done sharing what
they need at the time and they
developing me for for another week or
two okay so you also don't want to do a
lot of one-on-one work yeah
so with making videos and you want to be
do you need the input of questions or do
you prefer sharing on a topic that is
set that you've done research on I would
say the second option is probably the
best because I love to learn different
things and then share what I like okay
so a lot of my videos are based on that
where it is either concept that I see in
classroom or there's an idea that I
thought of or something in the news and
I get the science out of it we don't
need to go live and get questions
because you prefer
having a set theme from what you've
already learned that's true but I know
so much that I don't need as to set the
set theme so that's why I like the live
idea there's always a person or two that
has a question That Is Random then I
have to say okay I have three seconds to
make sense of it and then come up with
something and do you like that do you
like that okay so this is something
exciting okay so so you do both you can
have like lesson plans or things that
you've learned and make it easier for
people to understand than a typical
textbook
and live q a
that you're taking quite like this I
don't know what you're going to ask me
you know you show up you got this giant
sheet you know like oh my God but I like
I like the I like the spontaneity
because it's the we're going to create
something yeah out of this the the whole
idea of the uh the convention lesson
plan
I often
like to create new ideas all the time so
that is an option where I get lesson
plans or ideas and then I could just
Market those there's some websites where
they just you just put lesson plans for
teachers that are looking for lesson
plans and something to do so that's
another but that's now back to written
instead of video yes so let's have you
like let's design that video because all
of it could work but let's design a
video strategy for you that's going to
be more fun okay who do we want to serve
now do we want to do you like working
with students better teachers better
adults better do you want to do you want
to be the Scientific Advisor to the
Prime Minister like no I don't need to
be at the national level that's not
necessary I like to
so I like high school students from
Grade 9 to 12. okay because that's what
I'm used to and I also like teachers
that are always trying to look at new
pedagogies and ideas to help students
um I've also I've taught French
immersion for a long time so what
happened is I know a lot of things a lot
of Concepts and ideas on how to apply
strategies to help students so that's
something that I can do as well so
possibly even teachers are like equal
for you for fun I would say yes but
business wise there's probably more
resources from teachers than than from
students even though
students have possibly parents and
first-year teachers don't earn very much
to get help so
so these are these are yeah we'll figure
out a business models like starting with
like what do you what would be the most
fun to do you could wake up every day
and make videos that's going to help
students or wake up every day and make
videos it's going to help teachers is it
does it fall under equal level of
excitement and passion for you you were
to look at the business model the
business model would be for me to have a
place where I can
document my thinking process on how I
can help others but when people need
help I'm going to be there for them so
so I can just think of a website for
example where there'll be video
references and also so written and video
I like the idea no especially that now
in 2022 it's so easy to get the uh the
write-up or the script of a video so
someone in AI could do that so fairly
easily so I like I would like to do that
where every couple days there's a new
topic that can help students but can
help also teachers
it's just two different audience I know
right which is fine this is are they
equally exciting for you that's all
that's the questions like do you like
helping students and teachers the same
amount or is one more strategic like oh
I like helping teachers because they can
pay me yeah and that's the reason why
I'm doing it I don't think there's any
preference I enjoy both uh thoroughly
okay because students have when they
have questions it's amazing and adults
they're afraid of asking questions but
when you get them to ask questions then
it's exciting because it opens the door
for them to get better okay so and for
teachers I would say maybe the first 10
years because I think that they are
willing to ask questions and they're not
set in some ways and apologize for all
teachers out there so sometimes after a
while you get set in your way sometimes
so so first 10 years of the career I
think is exciting and so the content for
teachers would be about how to be a
better teacher or how to teach the
specific concept better to students
there'll be two parts one will be how to
better teach science okay and the other
one will be how to help students where
they they know two three or four
languages and they need to make sense of
what they need to learn so they can
succeed because if you think of there's
always new immigrants that are coming in
or in Canada we have French as a second
language or in Quebec we have English as
a second language so what happened is
there are so many languages available
but at some point in the school system
you need to feel comfortable so that you
can tell the audience or the teacher
what you can do like so you have two
models right like you've got you've got
the the mass the mass Market yeah and
that would be the students like it's
going to be hard to make money off of
individual students because
so so the path there becomes we have a
YouTube channel we're making uh content
as much as you can that is dedicated to
especially especially specific topics
like
you take the you take the the textbook
that you're teaching from now and you
make it easier yeah like the idea is
you're better than other teachers well
I'm not going to say that but I like to
think so well but but it's like you have
to at least feel that right you're not
gonna you're not gonna go out and say
that yeah
um or you might but you know Canadians
maybe a little a little more humble but
you have to at least feel that like
you're better than other teachers and
you can explain something that another
if I look at this school here like Alex
who teaches salsa I would put Alex
against any salsa instructor in North
America to teach
a complete beginner how to learn like
two left feet people like I can never
dance I'll put Alex against anybody in
North America and and put money on him
okay to be the best yeah like to get a
result is he the best like Advanced Pro
dancer maybe not but at that beginner
level
I'll put him against anybody in North
America right so you kind of you have to
feel like
you're really good at something if
you're gonna sell something right so you
are coming in like an average teacher
coming in who's just starting teaching
science in the grade 10 physics or
whatever I don't know if you live in
grade 10.
um but you can just teach it in a way
that's better than what's in the
textbooks and better than what most
teachers how they're teaching so you
believe that I believe that okay good
yeah for those who don't really have a
business and the thing is as as a as a
school system or any system people tend
to be following the mass and to get out
of the mass is sometimes a bit trickier
so my goal is following you for a long
time is how from the mass you can just
stand out of the mass but create the
inertia to get more people to get better
at what they do how different are the
curriculums across different provinces
or states for science
um I would say that in grade 8 9 10
they're very similar across the country
across the US yeah I would say so yeah
and then once you go to grade 11 and 12
then it's a bit more specialized so it's
a bit different depending on
are we using the same textbooks in grade
nine Ontario was like New York no they
have so they have for example they have
the Ontario Edition you may have the
western Canada Edition Quebec has
something different so but sometimes
it's just some of the units are
different so if you were to take grade 8
9 10 they learn the same thing but they
may not learn the same thing at the same
grade
so for example here's a guy this is fun
okay we're gonna it's all gonna make
sense I'm asking some questions to pull
it out and then we're gonna put it all
together there's a guy uh who has a
successful YouTube channel a couple
hundred thousand subscribers on how to
pass a driving test okay and it's had a
passive driving test in different states
because the the New York test is not
exactly the same as like
right so
where that becomes if you want to make
it really easy for students
and I sucked at science like I wish you
existed because I dropped science as
soon as I could I mean I guess you did
exist when I was doing it yeah
because I dropped it I felt like an
idiot I couldn't I couldn't get it
you know I couldn't learn it for
whatever reason and so like I'm gonna
drop it like I'm gonna go to the
business and drop science as soon as I
can and then I started biotech software
company there you go so but I wasn't the
Science Guy if you actually have a
better process and can do better video
lectures and help somebody understand it
where they're sitting there like I'm
imagining myself back in grade nine
my eyes are glazing over listening to
the teacher like I have no idea what's
happened I'm struggling to stay awake
and like focus on what he's saying and
I'm like I'm I'm lost then I go to the
textbook and I'm even more confused
because all these terms I don't
understand and I feel like I'm an idiot
if I could then go to your video and in
five minutes or 10 minutes or whatever
like oh
that's the plan yeah that makes sense
yeah
so the way to do it
for students is to follow along
the the curriculum that they're
following so that
I don't know how much variance there is
so it's like you understanding the good
news about science is there's probably
not a lot of change like Grade 9 science
from 10 years ago how different is it
from Grade 9 science very similar in
some ways yes that's true when you get
to higher level Concepts there's
probably some differences but it's
probably mostly the same like math has
it changed a lot it's grade 12 calculus
different than grade 12 calculus 20
years ago when I was doing it it's
probably the same right yeah so if you
could actually the way to win with
students is to create the videos
according to the themes and the lesson
plans that the teachers are going
through yeah like following the textbook
so that I could say this is my textbook
this is a I hate this textbook yeah I I
have PTSD looking at this textbook
so chapter one is going to be about
whatever yeah
yeah I can just go watch your video
instead you couldn't and often I do my
videos like on the live and then I edit
those and these are the videos I share
with my class because I change over the
years on how I share the information but
so the way to win in that model to hit
student no student well not no student
most students
don't want to actually get great at
science
they want to like they want to get a
decent score and they want to get a
decent grade in their class yeah and
they want to not feel like an idiot yeah
but they may not have Ambitions to go be
a scientist true but at least you're
you're like if I if I knew
um some of the concepts better from
grade nine science I'm sure would make
me a better person even if I never
wanted to become a scientist the you
have to keep in mind that even though
you take a science class even if you
don't like science the process of doing
a lab or thinking of a question and
coming to the end to answer the question
it the processes are very similar to all
of them if you're in art and you want a
specific blue and you have two different
colors
the proportion of how much of each color
you need to put together to get the
exact the exact color you want it's
you're doing it as an art person and a
lot of it comes down to the teacher yes
if you have a crappy teacher you could
say I suck at science yeah I hate
science because I have a crappy teacher
right same thing if you're in a job when
you hit your boss that's you hate your
job because you're a crappy boss yeah so
how difficult is it for you to create
videos according to Chapters in a
textbook
it's very easy for grade 9 and 10 I
could probably how many textbooks are
there across the country and U.S
oh there's hundreds I could probably not
go through all of them so like how many
different main ones are there I would
probably in a given year I know that in
the States you have a national science
Council so I could probably go through
them so throughout let's say grade eight
all the way to grade 12 they have a
series they have a curriculum so
actually I would not follow textbooks I
would actually go to the government
curriculums to see what they need to
learn and then create videos on what
they need to learn and not necessarily
following a textbook how much of the
tests like when teachers are going and
assigning tests for students comes from
stuff that's in the textbook
uh that's a good question some teachers
need the textbook as uh as a way to yeah
because they barely understand
themselves and and for me I use a
textbook for uh as as a reference yeah
or there are people that love reading
there's some people you just can't
handle videos so it's important to have
the two parts yeah yeah I mean I think
the easiest way is by following a
textbook yeah because
when the scientific advisory panel
whatever says we're going to learn this
the teacher might not teach it in the
same way yeah and so when this the
students what do they care about they
want to get it they don't want to fail
science class like why would I watch
your videos yeah I don't want to watch
your videos I just don't want to fail
science class like that's if you only
make videos targeting people who want to
learn science you've got a tiny
percentage of people yes if you want to
make videos with people who don't want
to fail science class now we've opened
it up to like every grade nine students
in America right so like this is how we
create something at scale so that
becomes basically online courses
there could be YouTube videos okay yeah
I would make those YouTube videos and
then you get that's how you hit scale
because if you if you're making YouTube
content but it's only reaching a tiny
percentage of people you're not making
enough money because you're not reaching
a lot of people now could you could you
have a low six-figure business probably
but like could you make something bigger
it's hard off of Just YouTube videos
that's targeting a small audience but if
you targeted people like how many people
in America which becomes the market much
more than Canada go through science like
everybody has to take Grade 9 science I
mean if you're in school if you dropped
out yeah fine but cool how many of those
students don't want to fail science
class almost everybody right if you said
how many of them want to get straight
A's not a lot of people like most people
don't think they can get straight A's
but how many don't want to fail most
people don't want to fail right they
don't want that F on their thing and
they don't want a d so your videos could
be if it's actually the hack like if you
are actually a better instructor than
their teachers the easiest way is
through the textbooks like this is your
textbook
the teachers are going they may not go
the textbook kind of word for word but
at least there's like assignments coming
from okay we're looking at chapter two
today we're looking at chapter three
today or chapter or not chapters or
sections or whatever but that becomes
easier to say here's your textbook
hear them here like there's 20 sections
in the book and here are the videos that
go along and teach you all of this stuff
like in an easier way and you would get
the income from advertisement on the
videos that's your that's your lowest
hanging fruit yeah is AD Revenue okay if
you actually then create a better model
like that that then leads to building a
brand where you're the better teacher
which then creates a lot of long-term
opportunities for you whether that's you
help design a better textbook you end up
speaking at these different events
talking to teachers you end up being
paid to come in and help form the next
scientific advisory Council to figure
out what the content should be it's like
lots of stuff that opens up
after you build a brand
the the path to build the brand is time
consuming and often doesn't pay so the
way to do it is through revenue from the
videos I see but to do it you need to
have a big enough base so when I
graduated from high school to University
we never took accounting class okay
accounting was uh I was too small a
school so like they didn't have enough
students to have an accounting class the
the weeder course in University first
year was accounting
like to decide whether you go on or not
like that's where they failed two-thirds
of the class and like you're gone and so
I was I was worried that
I know nothing about accounting and like
first year accounting at University of
Toronto was the hardest course yeah in
business so I got a textbook and I went
to summer school just to learn
accounting
I would have loved to take your
I see your videos no obviously you're
not doing accounting yeah um but it's
like it's like I don't want to learn
accounting it's boring you know a lot of
people like if that's who we ultimately
want to serve I don't want to learn
science I find it super boring I suck at
it I hate it
like oh I'm not actually that bad at it
I see right yep because that's most
people pull America and ask how many of
you are great at science and love it
it's a tiny percentage Yeah how do you
feel it's it's useless and and you suck
at it and you're bad at learning it like
well actually you're not you just don't
have the right method and teacher and
process right okay that's how we hit
scale that's fair so how many textbooks
are there
you know and what are the biggest
markets
so like what's the biggest education is
it California
is it New York City probably New York
City is it by state is it by City you
know is it is it Texas like if it's if
it's by State California has the most
people I think and then maybe Texas or
Florida uh so like that's part of that
and you can learn that right like that
that's an easy question to answer you
can find that out yeah but okay and how
many different textbooks are there
because if you could show me the picture
of the textbook and you'd label the
video like this textbook chapter two or
section two yeah
that if I'm the if I'm the student I can
go and watch that video like it's like
when when Cole's notes for the
Shakespeare like you don't want to read
nobody wants to read Shakespeare most
students right like if you're targeting
people who want to learn Shakespeare
it's one percent of people if that
that's true most people just want the
Kohl's notes tell me what the thing is
so I can pass a test and write the exam
and I'm not going to fail right okay so
it's interesting so effective but in
that process you're like you're giving
them what they actually want but then
you're you're also Gooding what they
need which is how to learn better and
realize that they're not idiots they
just don't have the process on how to
learn better right so you're giving them
the Kohl's notes basically for science
that's a good point for each book I like
that Shakespeare is too hard to
understand yeah you take a grade nine
student give them a Shakespeare book
it's like what is he even saying what is
this language it's not even English what
am I what am I reading yeah right and
you're making it make sense
so you're doing that because the same
thing when I I would actually rather
read Shakespeare than a science textbook
oh there you go like it makes
Shakespeare English makes more sense to
me than scientific words okay in a
textbook which which is a lot of people
they read it and it's all these words
they don't understand and concept they
don't understand yeah
yeah and you're going to make it easy
you're going to teach me how to do it
save the world and save the world let's
go so yeah so for the student side
that's the easiest path is you make you
I don't know how long it takes you to
make a video like you'll probably make
similar videos 30 times
okay like what's One Core Concept in
grade nine science uh for example
photosynthesis yeah photosynthesis or
the atoms that's where like plants
plants exactly get sunlight and turn it
okay perfect yeah photosynthesis right
of course you can barely say it you know
ask how many people know what that means
like you know probably a lot of people
would awesome so photosynthesis might be
in chapter one of this textbook in
chapter eight and this textbook in
chapter two in this textbook so you end
up making a similar video
14 different times for 14 different
textbooks
but I'm not coming you for the topic I'm
coming to you for the chapter
right
which is what students often would yeah
that's what they're going to go with
teachers would follow anyway to do their
courses and then both both audiences or
both group of people
well we're targeting most of the
students we're not necessarily teaching
the teachers yet how to be better this
is this is mass market for the students
okay but the way to do it is is to
follow the textbook yeah that's true I
like that
so how many textbooks are there how many
sections are there record go through the
whole book and make it like take the
most popular textbook to start with
I don't know how long like if you can do
and you probably can't do an entire
section in one video you might have to
break it up into different different
themes but those all become different
videos yeah
but it's easy now with with video
recording you can just do an hour and a
half long video with all the chapter and
then you just cut it in what you need so
that's easy yeah and then you might even
make it easy on yourself to when you
have your photosynthesis you can clip
that and put it into the other vid like
call it chapter four from this other
textbook so you're using the same video
for the different type if it makes sense
yep because is photosynthesis that
different for different textbooks no
it's like it's the same process same
thing yeah exactly so you're helping me
explain and understand what is
photosynthesis yeah right so you could
you just have to package it better
to follow the textbooks because that's
what students are following and that's
what a lot of the lazier teachers are
are following when you're in school and
your teacher is teaching eight subjects
they're not experts in all those things
you know there's following like what the
book says yeah that's true I was in a
physics class at Miguel and the person
who was teaching and then we I was
following in the textbook and the person
was even using the jokes from the
textbook yeah in his classes
so it's interesting how people can do
things sometimes so you just have to be
better than a textbook
I am better than Texas great so now I
have to see it it says like so then that
big I don't know how long it takes you
to make a video if you're gonna make a
video on photosynthesis does that take
you 20 minutes to do does it take you
four hours to do like in terms of
thinking about and prepping it obviously
the video itself wouldn't be four hours
but how long does it take you to get
ready and to film it and do you need
props and white boards or I usually have
a white board at the back and therefore
I need five minutes to to do any of the
topics to be honest with you I always
have a few textbooks around okay you
what grade do you teach right now nine
and ten okay pick your grade nine what's
your grade 9 textbook it's uh
it's a science Grade 9 textbook it says
how many pages is The and there's
probably 400 Pages how long would it
take you to make that in video uh let's
see there are four chapters no four
units
three units so that's four twelve
section
let's save
12 let's see
12 hours of filming probably
I don't know 36 hours of prepping and
putting in the pictures together but I
like to draw them because I'm worried
about the the
the copyright issues when I do the any
video so I'm very careful with that so I
do drawings which are bad but I'm good
yeah it's fun whatever
probably in 48 50 hours I could probably
do cover a whole textbook okay on the
topics and how many students does that
textbook how many people are using that
textbook so in the school there will be
so in my school maybe no not just your
school like the province well how much
is that textbook just for the profits is
that textbook that one is just for the
province yes so I don't know maybe 10
000 people maybe okay yeah every year
every year yeah
so it's reoccurring that becomes the the
math the figure out okay it's going to
take me 50 hours or 60 hours or whatever
to make this textbook and it's going to
cover 10 000 students cool let's go to
California it's gonna that textbook is
only 300 pages okay it's going to take
me
maybe still 60 hours because you're not
as familiar with that textbook because
you're here in Ontario and that's
California but it's going to serve 200
000 people I don't know like whatever
the calculus is okay to then figure out
what the best books are to go off and
cover
when you have concern that you'd have to
talk to the editor saying okay I'd like
to take your textbook and make videos
for them because you cannot just do do
it and not share with them that we're
using their textbook I think what are
your thoughts on that one no you just
need to like people do book people
taking Bill to serve
and done book reviews on it like you
can't read it word for word because then
that's their material okay right if if
you know I have an audiobook I built the
serve somebody took the audiobook and
posted it to YouTube I actually don't
mind but but my publisher who paid to
have the audiobook done would not be
happy that now it's free on YouTube
right so as long as you are doing it in
your your better teacher you're not just
going to come up and read word for word
you know that section 4 chapter 2 is on
photosynthesis so you're going to teach
me photosynthesis and that's why it
would take little time well 60 hours is
a lot of time but right I know all the
topics already so it's an easy thing
okay that's a great idea
so that becomes the process and then
like
whatever you made for Ontario how much
Ontario
textbook is similar to California
textbook it's going to be like 90
similar 80 similar 70 like it's not 20
similar right so the 60 hours that you
you made this course is going to be not
60 hours to do it for California because
you can use you just might have to
reorder
the different topics
because photosynthesis isn't taught till
the second chapter versus the eighth
chapter here or the first chapter here
and how would you package that would you
just just open open source on YouTube
which is easy yeah okay and you start
there okay yeah okay because then you
get the the audience and then you can
always come to you if they have
questions and then that's when the
business grows yeah okay and you make
money off the advertising revenue and
then the students a great thing is once
you get them once to watch one video
like oh the whole textbook's here yes
this is great okay that makes sense the
whole semester is here perfect does he
have grade 10 you know like they keep
coming back and then and then they tell
their friends in the classroom too like
you should go watch this guy's videos
like I understood it now I got an A on
my test because I watched Atlanta's
videos that's true they get A's well
that's what we want anyway okay
beautiful ideas so that's the model for
that's the that's the mass model right
and you could start doing that right
away I mean you're not doing it full
time yet but you start if you're talking
about A Five-Year Plan you start you
start chipping away at it that every
week you're making I don't know if you
can get out you probably can't get out a
textbook every week but you might
honestly like if you the first one might
take you a month or something to
actually make but after that you might
be able to do a textbook a week yeah
because all of that you can just read if
it's just me moving content around that
makes sense I like that and the goal
isn't even to get subscribers on the
channel like it's just for somebody to
want to watch that whole series because
they don't care about the other
textbooks they don't care really about
grade 11 biology unless they have to
take greater love and biology
I like that
it's interesting because if you go back
20 years that was one of the things I
wanted to do write a textbook and then
it just the idea just
went at the back of my head you still
might honestly like you still you that
becomes part of the brand like if you
build a brand so that people students
stop looking at textbooks and while
watching your videos instead which they
already are like they're already trying
to find like I would if I had YouTube
back in grade nine I'd definitely be
trying to understand these things from
uh somebody teaching it then try to
understand what was in my textbook
but you then will will have so many
opportunities
to write your own textbook to speak on
stages to whatever to work from there
because you built the brand yeah but
that's a process like you don't just get
nobody's going to call you right now and
say hey can you write a better textbook
I've got five years
because well because you don't have the
brand nobody knows you you know yet
right so that becomes part of the
process so that's the that's the that's
the student plan and you just go across
the whole country I would Target us
first unless you just love Canada this
is more this bigger Market ad rates are
higher more opportunities that makes
sense because I did start at my French
YouTube channel is going on for about
three years and the English one I
started about
two months ago yeah because I'm teaching
science in English right now so it's a
new new thing so it's exciting for
everybody
so English will just be way better okay
this is a bigger Market that's true yeah
so that's for the students for the
teachers
[Music]
um
if you you have two Paths of like how do
I help teachers just teach better but
then also how do I help them teach
science better yeah
whenever you're selling uh
like that could be a B2B play where you
don't necessarily need Mass you just
need to figure out who who would hire
you like would private schools hire you
to come in and help their teachers teach
better would I don't know what the
structure is in the U.S for schools like
funding for schools are not great
but there's also but for professional
development there's always right money
for that so that's like that is the
piece to learn
I see to figure out okay so you're not
going after teachers
one at a time one at a time one at a
time yeah you have a methodology that's
better and it's finding out how to how
to prove that and then whether it's
through professional development like
who are the organizations
who would hire you because you don't
want to have to go into an individual
school and do it because it's too much
Outreach it's too much leg work it's not
enough money one school at a time
so who are the organizations that sell
the training that you could go in and do
training
that makes sense actually you talked
about that in the business development
we in the movement maker last week okay
okay some learning to do some work to do
it's exciting so those are the two paths
right so like that that is actually
probably a it's a it's a little bit of
learning and work to figure out who are
the people and who are the names and how
do I get in touch and how do I do my
first Workshop there or how do I get in
on their training system but then once
you have that it's ongoing Revenue it's
it's money in your pocket right away
and there's always new teachers and they
always need training so there's always a
need for you whether that's on a
national level and again think U.S more
than Canada yeah is it a national level
is it state by state is it county by
county like I don't know but you can
figure that out pretty quickly yeah I'm
sure I have no doubt about that how do
how do what does professional
development look like for teachers is it
public schools only is there a private
school like I was here and you said it
had to be Ontario I'd look at private
schools so you just have way more budget
yeah than public schools so that path
starts bringing she said hey I have to
make money
like as soon as possible then then
that's the path to go okay Target
teachers professional development you
have a better way you do one Workshop or
one training even it's for free just for
their members just to show that you're
good at it so that people say oh my God
that was great I had a way what's round
two how do we get Ella to come back
right and then you get paid to to do
these different workshops for their
teachers okay
and then the student side is the mass
side
because it's no nobody's gonna it's that
I can think of hire you to come in and
teach science better so you do it
on scale
with videos yeah and then if you want to
throw in Q and A's and fun things or
even just whatever you learn that you
want to share there's not as much of a
business model around that okay
but going textbook by textbook to hit
the math so you've got an idea you got
your student model you got your teaching
model both both can work both are
hopefully fun yep
let me change the world
Tesla plan very nice a billion moment of
learning so does it fit does it feel
right it does it does feel right did we
address some of that I don't know what's
on the sheet yeah so the big question I
I had was how do I set it up so so for
example so I don't want to name it some
platform where you can put online
courses for example or you can just have
a website to put the information there
or just YouTube the idea is where to
send centralize my information that is
my next question and be indeed the hot
seat today yeah with the other people I
might come up with some ideas I would I
would do YouTube yeah YouTube for free
for students that's what I've been doing
so far but more I can go by the textbook
yeah okay chapter by chapter in the
textbook because that's how that's how
they'll find it and look for it
um and then teachers is you have to find
the contacts how do they do professional
development
so YouTube would be the platform I would
not even have need something else at
this time or in an email maybe so the
thing with courses like it's not that
you couldn't do courses and teach it
better and go according to the textbook
and courses the problem becomes
marketing
how are you going to Market those who's
going to pay for it now you're asking a
student
to pay to learn the subject that's
hopefully better it's just all small
okay if you're selling courses it's
better to Target adults
and ideally even even courses for adults
is rough like it's still better to do it
through an association like if you had a
course I had to be a better teacher that
then you can sell to a teacher's
Association or professional Development
Association that's great that's a great
course
so like how to be a better teacher is a
great course so you can sell to whatever
organization okay
the students you're just this it happens
a lot you're gonna how much are they how
much you're gonna spend on it like
you're not gonna spend 100 bucks on a
course on how to be better at science
like some people might there's like a
tiny little percentage of people okay
right but to one hit your goal of
helping a billion moments of learning
yeah uh but also two like start
monetizing it YouTube okay your videos
are on YouTube and then your course for
teachers is through you don't even need
to have it hosted somewhere like it's
through their organization okay oh I see
okay that makes sense like you as an
Ontario teacher where do you you have to
do professional development yes and
usually offered by the board so if it
comes from how you're up it goes to the
board and then the board shares the
information to teachers and then you go
to a website or you what how do you get
it from the board uh usually there are
trainers coming in to share the
information so that's usually what
happens all in person there's nothing
online uh there's more and more things
online so
have you taken any online courses from
from the board
no just from universities where the
boards recognizes some some professional
developments from different universities
and that counts towards your
professional development yes okay so
it's like how do you get how do you get
in there I see that makes sense so
either how do you get recognized as an
individual or how do you partner with a
university to have a accredited course
okay or how do you
connect directly with the the school
board to have an accredited course it
has to count as a credit otherwise
teachers are like that's correct they
mean they might take it but they're
probably not going to take it right so
how do you get an accredited course but
so that's where it's like you need to
figure out that model and then wherever
they want you to house it that's where
you house it okay it's not like
there's no accredited courses from
skillshare
right or whatever there's lots of places
to be able to post your course but they
don't count as accredited courses for
students for teachers to be able to go
off and take okay so for the for your
student model YouTube is your platform
for the teacher model whatever platform
you need to be on is the platform that
like it's so their internal platform
like if University of Toronto is going
to have you come and have an accredited
course on how to be a better teacher
that's going to account for high school
teachers in Ontario they'll tell you it
has to be on our system that makes sense
okay so you design your course it then
goes and fits on their system
that's easy simple yeah and all the
other all the other platforms don't
matter so what you're trying to sell
yeah exactly at this time okay
I love it
very nice let's go yes it's gonna happen
for sure pleasure
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe see you there